[Music]
hi and welcome to episode number 151 of
the weekly Google cloud platform podcast
I'm ma Crandall and I'm here with my
extra-special colleague Melanie where I
key today Melanie hey Marc I'm good how
are you I'm very well it's Monday
beginning of the week
it's Monday welovemondays is good though
when you're listening to this this will
be Wednesday yes
so mark who do we have on the podcast
this week yeah so this week we are
talking about Java and jib with Patrick
Flynn and Mike else ofin yeah so we're
talking about spring bird we're talking
about jib which is a tool for creating
darker files from Java so it's basically
a lot of Java ecosystem stuff but as we
do we always start out with our cool
things of the week and we end with the
question of the week and this week's
question all the way from mark what if
we have an object in Google Cloud
storage and I want to automatically
change an aspect of it such as downgrade
the storage class of objects older than
365 days took cold line storage delete
objects created before January 1st 2013
or keep only the three most recent
versions of each object in a bucket with
versioning enabled mark where did this
come from actually something I needed to
do a while ago and I came across it
again I was like that's a great question
of the week sounds like a plan
all right well the cool thing is a week
let's get that kicked off and Mark I
think you have something from kubernetes
right oh I always have something from
kubernetes so this is pretty cool this
is a introducing container native load
balancing on google kubernetes engine so
this is this is quite neat in that
previously you know you've had things
like ingress you've had services that's
open really great and generally speaking
that's been fine usually when that works
it comes down through the nose and
through IP tables and then directly into
the pods and sort of routed through
kubernetes itself this cloud native load
balancing works a little bit more
efficiently in that it comes straight
into a network endpoint group and
actually gets passed directly into the
pubs themselves so it basically provides
optimal load balancing native support
for health checking some graceful
determination optimal data paths and
increased visibility and security so
it's quite a neat little project you
should probably check it out it is the
network endpoint groups so check that
out and we'll have links it's a good
post and it's also got great visuals
which we're always a fan of yep another
cool thing of the week that we want to
mention is there's a post we're going to
share that simplifying cloud networking
for enterprises and it's basically
announcing the cloud net and the cloud
net is a new Google managed network
address translation service
that's not basically you can provision
your application instances without
public IP addresses and that still
allows you to access the internet so it
gives you the ability and some
functionality around that in terms of
like firewall rules logging managing the
TLS certificates for HTTP load balancers
you don't have to do that manually you
can use their a more automated system
and there's a number of new load
balancing features that they share you
know things like user-defined request
headers and network tiers for load
balancing and cloud armor and so forth
so you can check it out I quite like
this because whenever I see it I think
to myself like in that router is what I
have at home but now they just have like
Google Wi-Fi points in the data center
or some yeah yeah good point
all right and next up so we've got some
great new announcements for cloud
storage as well and there's several of
them which is pretty neat so we have a
new dual region option available in beta
which i think is really nice so
previously like we've had multi region
and we've had single region now you
wouldn't actually do dual region so if
you want some redundancy but you want to
have particular locality or particularly
close to say where you want to do your
computation you can choose that as an
option as well and that's in beta at the
moment apparently it's also strongly
consistent so when you create a do a
live region bucket then follow up and
request to fetch a list of certain
resources your resources will be in that
response yeah which is great yes also
the availability has been raised for
Nearline and cold lights data and multi
region locations so Google is raising
its availability SLA for an airline and
cold line data in multi region locations
from ninety nine point zero percent to
ninety nine point nine percent so that's
actually a decent raise okay and
basically the new cloud storage as a C++
client library yes and I like C++
because games the last thing we want to
mention for the week is that our friends
Liz and Seth who did this great sre
podcast with us a little while back they
just released another video on
post-mortems and retrospectives for
essays and DevOps and so this is a nice
video that covers you know how to handle
post mortems and especially doing
blameless post mortems which is a real
crucial thing and so you can check this
out
definitely and if you hadn't listened to
the episode before it's episode number
127 and we'll make sure to put a link in
that in the show notes as well agreed
great all right mark I think it's time
to get into the interview yeah let's go
talk with Patrick and Mike well I'm very
excited today to have two staff software
engineers working on some interesting
projects for Java fruit Google cloud we
have Patrick Flynn and Mike else ofin
hopefully I got that right how are you
both doing Patrick how're you doing
today I'm doing great thanks how are you
I'm good how you doing Mike pretty good
how's it going good well thank you both
for joining us today I really appreciate
you both taking the time well we really
appreciate it I should say before we get
started I know we've got a lot of fun
and interesting things happening in the
Java ecosystem for Google cloud but why
don't you tell us a little bit about who
you are and what you do Patrick why
don't you go first you know my name is
Patrick Flynn I'm the tech lead of the
Java tools team for Google cloud we
build all kinds of useful little tools
for our Java developers who target cloud
if you're familiar with App Engine we
own the IDE and build integrations that
you can find IntelliJ and eclipse and
maven in Gradle for App Engine and
lately we've been focusing on the
kubernetes workflow and how to make that
less painful experience for Java
developers and ice and how about you
Mike
yeah so I'm also a software engineer in
Google cloud I'm a tech lead of a team
called cloud Java frameworks and we've
been recently focusing mostly on
building integrations between Spring
Framework and Google cloud and bringing
all that goodness of Spring Framework
spring boot to cloud users suite so it
sounds like there are what is it two big
projects that are happening I don't know
who can give us an overview of like the
new stuff that's been happening for Java
developers because it sounds like
there's been some cool stuff happening
so I guess from my point of view in
terms of the frameworks we just released
a few months ago the first official
version of spring cloud GCP which is the
project that does this integration
between Spring Framework and Google
cloud so that's that's been new and
that's pretty exciting for us and I
think a large part of the Java developer
community would be excited about it as
well because we're making it a lot
easier now for spring developers to take
advantage of Google cloud api's that's
from my point of view there's also a
bunch of tools that Patrick's team is
working on and you could talk about that
yes yeah I guess the latest thing that
we've released for tools has been jib
which is a Java specific container
builder for those who might not know can
you tell us a little bit more about what
our spring frameworks sure for so Spring
Framework has been around for a long
time well over ten years now it started
as a dependency injection framework for
Java and it was also sort of an
alternative to the j ee framework that a
lot of people were using to build
enterprise applications it has grown
quite a bit since then and it's become
more of an umbrella framework with all
kinds of integrations for you know
enterprise application development and
in the past few years they also brought
spring boot which made it even easier to
build enterprise applications by taking
advantage of this kind of principle of
convention over configuration so that
that's spring and spring boot they're
fairly popular today among Java
developers especially the enterprise
applications and that's part of the
reason why we are focusing on that
framework
what's our integration there what are we
actually doing to make like spring and
spring boot easier for Google cloud
platform because I mean springs in
inversion of control framework and
spring boots
n-b-c type framework so what's the deal
there so there's a lot of things in
Spring Framework spring boot a lot of
those things are integrations with
existing kind of tools that are useful
for enterprise application development
like messaging systems different
databases they really try to make it
very easy to use those however there are
no out-of-the-box integrations at least
in the past that would work with Google
Cloud so what we've done is we basically
look at all the different sub projects
within Spring Framework and try to find
a match in the Google cloud API and
services where we could apply those
abstractions and idioms and implement
those bindings essentially so we've done
it for a bunch of different services in
Google cloud now including databases
like spanner data store cloud sequel as
well as messaging so pops of storage
configuration almost anywhere where
there is some kind of match between
bring framework and Google cloud we try
to make that work
through spring so does the Spring
Framework have like some kind of higher
level abstraction is that how the
developer sees thing is that how that
works yeah they have a whole bunch of
abstractions for different purposes for
example for databases they have a
project called Spring data there are
some interfaces and abstractions that
apply across different spring data
implementations but they also leave the
flexibility to can expose the specific
features of a database through that as
well
so as much as like spanners the
relational database but there are some
you know very unique features of spanner
and we're able to expose the unique
features as well as kind of comply with
idiomatic Spring data interfaces so that
people can easily migrate from one
database to another yeah they're still
able to use the unique features if they
need to why is Google investing why does
this matter for Google to develop spring
cloud for GCP we care about Java
developers we want them to be happy on
GCP so we can't really care now we care
we really want to make that experience
great for them and we know that a lot of
Java developers are on Spring Framework
and we really want to make it as easy as
possible for them to move their
applications to GPU or write new
applications using spring framework or
DCP and we know that there are a bunch
of benefits to using Spring Framework
and spring booth like for example it
eliminates a lot of the boilerplate code
that you have to write so it's a lot
easier to get started with we're really
trying to meet developers where they are
and where they are is this is using
Spring Framework because as far as we
could tell it makes sense from like a
developer perspective like how do I set
this up like if I have a GCP project do
I need to like import credentials or is
it like seamless how does this kind of
work yeah so we have a bunch of spring
boot starters
so I mentioned convention over
configuration so we tried to make you
configure too many things and instead
order discover whenever possible yet
allowing also to override those defaults
with credentials for example as soon as
you bring in our like course starter
from sprinkler DCP it will try to order
detect credentials wherever you're
running if you're running locally it
will try to find your local credentials
that you've set up using environment
variables or g-cloud if you're running
on GCP
i will also try to order discover the
normal
places where you'd find like the
credentials on GCE
what have you alternatively you could
always specify a path to you know the
key so we will let that to be a
possibility as well and for a lot of
these things like we kind of make
assumptions for the configuration and
you can always override that I guess
that's nice then it means if I'm using
like spanner or Google Cloud storage as
a development thing I don't have to have
that locally in my local environment can
just talk straight up to whatever my
development environment is if you
develop it locally and you want to
expand there of course it will need to
talk to spanner remotely because there
is no emulator for spanner yep if you
already have g-cloud setup and you set
up credentials it will automatically use
those to connect to span you don't need
to really configure anything you just
add their starter and L will work out of
the box I was gonna ask what are some of
the challenges you seen that you're
working on trying to address for some of
the users now at first one we started we
were trying to basically guess what the
developers will need like which parts
exposed to the spring extractions and
which ones we should hide it's
challenging when you don't really have
too many users giving feedback initially
but now that we've kind of gone through
the first official release we're getting
a lot more feedback on getting users
engaged on github so it's it's getting a
bit better to set direction on what we
should be focusing on and that there are
so many different possibilities where we
could do integration between spring and
GCP and just prioritizing those things
are sometimes difficult so getting the
user feedback is very important now that
sounds great this project is actually a
close collaboration with the spring team
the creators of the Spring Framework and
pivotal which is the company that houses
them we've been working with them from
the very beginning on this and they've
been helping set direction of this
project and they've been be actively
guiding us throughout the whole process
we frequently meet with them and talk
about you know design implementation all
of that so it's a very close partnership
with pivotal spring team on this so we
have that expertise being funneled into
the project as well as kind of from our
side the Google Cloud expertise
excellent so if I'm running a spring
period application and I'm not that
familiar with that ecosystem are there
any like restrictions on where I can run
that up like is it just on a app engine
maybe or just in a docker container or
yeah at this point you can pretty much
run anywhere
it works on App Engine it works on
kubernetes it works on GC whatever you
can run java yep something good is
essentially an executable jar so
whatever you can run that it can also
run as a war file so if you're using
like App Engine standard you could also
do it there
so speaking of runtimes we have some new
tools for being able to run Java
applications inside containers Patrick I
know you're joining us today to talk us
about that do you want to give us a
little rundown on Jib yeah be happy to
so what is Jab Jib is basically an
answer to what should be the right way
to containerize a java application the
thing that kind of stands out about
using Jib from the way that people
traditionally containerize using docker
files there are a few things really the
first is that you don't need a docker
daemon running on your machine which
requires root and that kind of suits a
lot of people as well as Enterprise CI
environments which have problems with
that that wasn't the focus for why we
built chip but it was kind of a nice
surprise that a lot of users adopted it
for that reason the the main reasons we
focused on on building Jib is because we
felt that the way that people were
packaging containers using docker file
tended to be inefficient so jib
typically will build the docker
container kind of marginally faster in
your first build but then the
incremental builds can be dramatically
faster depending on the project and then
the other aspect of jade that's pretty
important is that it's much more
declarative well you know docker file
will allow you to kind of run arbitrary
commands and therefore is pretty much
not a reproducible build a jib build
config is declarative and that makes it
really easy for end-users to understand
it means that we can set a lot of
defaults which means that you have to
configure very little to get started and
it allows our tooling to sort of
incrementally optimize both the build
and the eventual runtime so yeah it's
just it just makes it a lot easier for
Java developers who have this hump of
needing to turn their traditional
packaging formats into containers so
they can target new platforms like
kubernetes and from like a developer
perspective how do I use Jim right good
question
first off I'll start with a little bit
of context jib actually came from the
this local container guru at Google
called Matthew Moore
if you're not familiar with basil basil
is this google build system which we use
internally in which we've open-sourced
recently he built a bunch of
containerize errs for basil that worked
very much like jib but what we've seen
is that basil is like a big hump for
people to adopt a better way to
containerize our applications most of
our java users are on maven or Gradle so
what Jib does is it takes a lot of that
strategy that the basil rules use and
implements it as Java library and
integrates it into maven and Gradle
plug-ins so if you wanted to use chip
all you have to do is just set up your
pom.xml your build.gradle to use our
plugin and the most minimal config you
really need is just specifying where
your container registry images should be
pushed you'd mention about jib being
more efficient than docker can you
explain a little bit more about how it
is more efficient you know first of all
I think docker file was a really great
sort of solution initially to bring
people into the world of containers
right it's very flexible and it gives
people the tools they need to take
whatever arbitrary packages they have
and containerize them that being said
you really need to understand a lot of
things about how docker works to
optimally package your apps and have a
good incremental build time so the first
thing that we do is we kind of
standardized way that we build our
images and we layer them in a way that
makes more sense for increment ality so
for instance your dependencies or like a
lot of projects could have tens or
hundreds of megabytes of jars that they
use in their project your dependencies
will be put into a docker layer that
will probably not change very often and
your source code and your resources also
go into separate layers what that means
is that when you do an incremental build
instead of having to repackage the
entire container and push you know
possibly hundreds of megabytes
you'll probably if your classes are only
a few megabytes you'll only have to push
that change to the registry to actually
get that new image out there how does
this work with that Ducker like is this
magic everything's magic I always
assumed that there's a lot of magic
there for when you kind of dig into the
container image spec it's not that
complicated it's really a bunch of
tarballs with metadata so that's what
the layers are right kind of like these
concentric tarballs
so we just built the library that
anybody can use actually if they want to
integrate it
to their system of choice to help you
build a container image using gelatin
this is nice does this fit anywhere
specifically into like a kubernetes
workflow or there any hooks in that way
yeah that's a good question the funny
thing is you know if you talk to
kubernetes developers there's not really
much of a standard around a workflow
most people are kind of asking me about
what their workflow should be which is a
shame because I want to I want to find
out what theirs is and the one tool that
we've seen gained significant atop
adoption has been scaffold which is a
CLI tool also provided by Google that
basically will watch your micro service
project or a set of micro service
projects based off of a llamo because
this is kubernetes and will actually
trigger rebuilds and push those images
and update your cluster config so that
you kind of get like a hot reload feel
from your application assuming that your
container builds are fast enough so what
we've been doing is trying to make sure
that scaffold users who are Java users
have a decent experience scaffold and
Java is not great at the moment because
I guess you can imagine a file watcher
that basically rebuilds in every file
change for Java doesn't necessarily make
sense especially given like how have you
wait some Java builds can be so we've
been looking at that some users have had
actually some pretty good success by
using this task that we have in both of
our plugins which generates a docker
context so you get effectively kind of
the docker version of what Jim would
have created and pointing scaffold of
that because scaffold understands
stalker but we're actually working
currently with the scaffold team to
build like a jib build or for scaffold
yes and that should be available within
the month or so what are you enjoy most
about working with Jim and with Java
what I like about working with [ __ ] is
that I don't have to think too much
about containerization and what I think
is powerful also about the way that Jim
packages your app right because Jim
doesn't take your jar or your uber jar
or your wor and put it into a docker
container it understands Java right it
understands that you have resources
classes and libraries and it lays out a
file system and the real package is a
container right I think what people have
sort of missed about containerization is
that they've started like packaging
their package
and a lot of the complexity that you see
in the Java ecosystem around like uber
jars or like executable jars right
they're not really relevant in a
container world where you have your
entry point and you can just arbitrary
layout files any way that you like and
make it work because you have control
over the job of invocation and so like
that's what kind of excites me about jib
and the way it makes containers a native
packaging format for Java nice the Java
ecosystem itself I just think it's
amazing how long it's lasted and how
huge it is and it's incredibly important
for Google I think Java is the largest
codebase internally at Google and we
work with the internal Java team as well
a lot of the inspiration for the way
that jib works comes from the way that
Google container eise's applications and
has been for many years now I just love
the community out there to you know I
don't know if you've heard of a hipster
and spring micronaut there's just a lot
of innovation actually happening in that
ecosystem as well as the new jvm
languages that are getting popular like
Kotlin in particular with adoption it's
had an Android it's just really exciting
so I'm wondering if I'm going to date
myself for how long I've been out of the
Java ecosystem let's say I'm building a
web server with something like jib I
assume I still need to embed something
like a jetty or something that actually
runs the server like how do I tell it
like how do I expose ports like is there
is there best practices there yes
currently the type of applications that
we support in jib are only the like Java
- right type applications and not war
style applications although we're adding
more support and that should be
available pretty soon so anything that
you could run on your machine using Java
- CP would will work in jib and what
people typically do for web servers is
either they use spring boot or some
analog of that so I'm showing my age
micro not is another framework there's a
play framework
there's a bunch there's like so yes from
the spring boot point-of-view
it produces a jar but it really embed
either Tomcat or jetty or more recently
it's actually able to use like a
lower-level API which is called Neddie a
native server it's much more lightweight
its reactive so it's really cool in the
new version of spring you could use that
as well and you know since this is
Google you can also obviously create a G
RPC endpoint of course very easily and
package that and since you brought it up
mike is there like a jib spring boot
Google Cloud
mashup musical thing happening at some
point is it a thing like is there a
workflow that way especially musical it
needs to be musical music oh yeah I'm
probably not the best person for the
musical part but we can get help for
that there's no reason why I shouldn't
work I'm pretty sure people have done it
I'm not Patrick feel aware of any
samples demos that we have for them you
know they're very orthogonal tools so
they just work well together I think
that there was a demo at Spring one 4k
night is where you can actually one of
the cool things about both maven and
Gradle is that you don't actually have
to configure a plug-in internally in
your build file to actually use it so
what a key native does with their build
templates they have a jib build template
that you can basically check out any
spring boot project and it'll build a
container without modifying the project
at all so that's a really nice and easy
and you point to just go from an
arbitrary spring boot project is
something that's running in cádiz the
other thing with spring boots you really
write very little code in spring boot
there's a lot of other dependencies you
might bring in and while do you
developing the application the fact that
you only modifying is like one class
file it makes it very efficient to
update your container because it doesn't
have to update all those other
dependencies that are not changing in
the process of the development so how
can developers get involved in
contributing to these projects raincloud
GCP is obviously open source you can
find us on github we love all kinds of
contributions feedback issue submissions
bugs or requests all that is welcome we
always love when we see you know the
community contributing and getting
involved in the project so just get on
our github and go from there yeah I
would say the same for jib we have think
it's called git er chat from our github
page you can find it under the Google
container tools org there's also cig app
which we attend regularly this which is
a kubernetes special interest group
which talks about some of these things
and the Java and scaffold slacks on
kubernetes the scaffold one definitely
has a lot more people talking than the
Java one but I'd love to see more people
participate in that slack Channel and we
I think scalpel also has a public
bi-weekly meeting that people are
welcome to attend as well so if
somebody's new like never done anything
with spring or with jib or with Java and
they are interested how would you
recommend them getting involved
they have never used spring there are a
lot of sample projects we have in our
github repo you can get started with we
have pretty good documentation and
spring itself is great documentation
there are so many books and strings and
tutorials you can find
besides that we actually have code labs
google cloud that you can follow along
I'll go to cloud and just get things
running we'll link to that and that's
just you can experience it right away
without really knowing too much about
how to build applications with spring or
GCP cool Thank You Patrick anything on
your head the best source of
documentation for jib is our github page
cool excellent thank you well before we
wrap up today is there anything that you
want to make sure that our listeners
know you can be at any events is there
anything we haven't covered in the
podcast anything at all we'd love to
hear it I just want to say that even
though we were ready to release the one
o GA release of the project we were
adding so many new features right now
and they're coming out soon we're
bringing support for data source so
spring data data store is coming soon
we're looking into the reactive API so
look out for all those new things coming
and and we would happy to hear your
feedback on you know helping us set the
direction my team is going to be at coop
con in Shanghai and at Oracle code one
and I'll be at KU Con in Seattle so if
anybody wants to get in touch me
definitely feel free to reach out I'd
love to talk to people
I'll see you there cool well thank you
both for coming on the podcast thanks
for having us yeah thank you very much
was a blast thanks Cheers Thank You
Patrick and Mike for coming on the
podcast it was great to talk to you guys
about Java jib spring all the things
yeah absolutely it's actually really fun
I haven't touched Java in a really long
time so it was a really nice chance to
revisit the ecosystem I know a little
while for me as well so mark let me ask
you the question of the week as we never
do what if we have an object in Google
Cloud storage and I want to
automatically change an aspect of it and
some of the examples that we were
mentioning is like downgrading the
storage class of objects older than 365
days too cold line storage which
definitely good question considering I
know a number of people hear about cold
line but they don't particularly think
about it deleting object created before
a certain date like January 1st of 2013
or something and keeping only the three
most recent versions of each object in a
bucket with versioning enables yes
this is something I actually also came
across to for the project I work on our
chronic on is and we have development
very builds we have development
artifacts that go into Google Cloud
storage with every PR that comes in and
obviously that could grow to really
large proportions so what I wanted to be
able to do is basically say is if there
was a bill that's older than 30 days and
just delete it like we don't care I was
thinking oh maybe I have to write a
script or do all that kind of stuff I
didn't want to do that work but within
Google Cloud storage there's actually
think old object lifecycle management
which is really really handy and you can
do this through gsutil you can do it
through the console can do it through
REST API as to but basically you can
kind of just wander into the console and
grab a bucket and select some object
conditions say what age it is maybe or
the creation date or what storage class
it currently is and then you can say
like what is the action that I want to
take do I want to say this Nearline do I
want to set this to cold line maybe I
wanted to lead it and I can put these
across my buckets which is really nice
as well and so this means then that it's
really easy to be able to do some pretty
good management of the stuff that you
have in Google Cloud storage and control
both your costs and also how much stuff
you store and and where it goes without
having to really write any code or do
anything like that it's kind of just
built in which is super nice
yeah going anywhere special next couple
weeks next couple of months no I'm not
really I'm gonna take some vacation at
some point in November but outside of
that I will be at cue come in December
which I'm super excited about you're
going on vacation you're not allowed to
go on vacation yeah I'm going on
vacation in November bye good luck
alright so anyways you're saying cube
con and December keep coming December
which I'm really really excited about
what do you up to you so this week
Twilio conference signal and github x'
conference universe are happening this
week a lot of people are in town a lot
of things are happening I'm planning on
actually going to to Leo's bash event on
Thursday so if anybody's gonna be there
feel free to come up and say hi and then
at the end of November I will be at soup
mole what is so cool I have no clue now
it's an unconference in the machine
learning space it'll be good home to
connect with people on so looking
forward to it
excellent yeah fantastic all right
Melanie well thank you for joining me on
the podcast yet again this week good to
talk to you mark and thank you all for
listening and we'll see you all next
week
[Music]